digamos que por aquí tengo la función fx
fx y esta función es igual a 2 x 3 2 x
menos 3 y también me voy a tomar a la
función gx que la voy a poner con este
color que de x la cual voy a decir que
es un medio de x + 3 un medio de x + 3
de lujo y lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es evaluar
efe efe deje de x déjame ponerlo así efe
de g de x
de gdx y también voy a evaluar cuánto es
g de fx y bueno primero vamos a evaluar
efe gx así que es buen momento para que
pausa es el vídeo y veas si lo puedes
resolver por tu cuenta
muy bien vamos a resolverlo juntos quién
es
efe de gds esto va a ser igual y bueno
cada vez que veamos una equis en la
definición de fx la entrada ahora va a
ser gtx entonces vamos a reemplazar las
equis por gdx y que me va a quedar me va
a quedar 22 que multiplican a gtx déjame
ponerlo así que multiplica a g de x esto
menos 3 esto menos 3 pero bueno sabemos
que gtx es esta función que tengo aquí
así que déjame sustituirlo me va a
quedar 2 que multiplican que multiplica
ag de x pero gdx es un medio de x un
medio de x
3 y bueno a todo esto hay que quitarle 3
hay que quitarle 3 de lujo y después voy
a distribuir este 2 multiplicando
primero a un medio de equis y después a
3 y que me va a quedar bueno me va a
quedar 2 por un medio de x eso es lo
mismo que x que x 2 por 36 y después
tengo este menos 3 - 3 muy bien y ahora
vamos a hacer seis menos tres y entonces
me va a quedar x más 3 es decir que f
deje de x es x más 3
ya tenemos esta primera parte de lujo
esto se ve muy interesante pero ahora
vamos a evaluar g de fx bueno pues vamos
a ponerlo por aquí me voy a tomar
y ahora en lugar de poner a x voy a
poner la función fx gm de f de x y bueno
esto va a ser igual a quien esto va a
ser igual a en lugar de poner a x voy a
poner a fx y me va a quedar un medio que
multiplica a fx que multiplica a efe de
x ya esto habrá que sumarle 3 habrá que
sumarle 3 de lujo y cuantos esto bueno
pues esto va a ser igual a un medio y en
lugar de fx voy a poner 2x menos 3 un
medio que multiplica a 2x menos 3 y esto
a su vez habrá que sumarle 3 esto a su
vez le sumamos 3 y ahora vamos a
distribuir este un medio un medio por 2
x eso es lo mismo que x y después un
medio que multiplica a menos 3 eso me va
a quedar igual a menos
medios y esto más tres y bueno tres es
lo mismo que seis medios y seis medios
menos tres medios es lo mismo que tres
medios positivos tres medios positivos y
ya está
este es g de fx así que observa
definitivamente obtuvimos cosas
distintas para efe gx y gdf de equis y
tampoco regresamos directamente a equis
entonces con esto sabemos que éstas no
son funciones inversas entre sí de hecho
solamente tenemos que hacer la
evaluación de fx o de gdf de equis para
saber si son o no son inversas entre sí
así que en definitiva estas no son
funciones inversas así que déjame
escribirlo así
efe de x f de x no es lo mismo que la
inversa deje de x que la función inversa
d
de equis y tampoco de equis gtx es la
función inversa de fx así que lo voy a
poner así tampoco es la función inversa
de f de x de hecho para que sean
funciones inversas recuerda que tiene
que pasar lo siguiente si tú por aquí
tienes a equis y después le aplicamos la
función de x déjame ponerlo así le
aplicamos la función g le aplicamos la
función g llegamos a este punto de aquí
que es g de x le estamos aplicando la
función g y después si ponemos como
entrada a la función g y le aplicamos la
función inversa de gm entonces
tendríamos que llegar a x aquí le
aplicamos la función inversa de g y
deberíamos de ser capaces de regresar al
mismo lugar pero entonces esta vez no
llegamos al mismo lugar
claramente regresamos al valor de x + 3
lo mismo sucede en este
otro caso vemos que no regresamos a x
regresamos al valor de x tres medios por
lo tanto en definitiva estas no son
funciones inversas entre sí